[Musique]
loyers excessifs appartement souvent
pris d'assaut dossier impossible à
monter le parcours pour trouver un
logement et souvent semée d'embûches
sans compter les multiples et arnaque
immobilière où les escrocs débordent
d'imagination pour vous soutirer de
l'argent qu'est ce qui nous arrive et
des arnaques les plus courantes
l'élongation fantôme de vos annonces
mises en ligne par de faux propriétaire
qui demandent des versements de dépôt de
garantie pour vous garantir la location
mais aussi l'usurpation d'identité
souvent réalisées lors que vous remettez
votre dossier avant une visite où les
escrocs vont pouvoir utiliser vos
informations personnelles pour créer de
faux papiers bref de nos jours les
arnaques immobilières sont nombreuses et
il faut toujours bien se renseigner
avant d'entamer quelconque démarche
heureusement ce soir notre spécialiste
en immobilier d'aligre aux manettes avec
nous et il va vous donner toutes les
astuces pour flairer les arnaques et
pour ne plus jamais vous faire avoir
david bowman bonsoir bienvenue dans tpm
était alors c'est vrai que c'est alors
je crois que tous on a été on été
victimes d'au moins une fois dans sa vie
d'une arnaque lambert plus ou moins
graves dans mon cas ça a été extrêmement
grave combien de la baraque 2 millions 7
mai vous êtes vous rencontrés c'était
quoi la remarque bas c'était un million
sept cent
c'était un immeuble qui a fait qu'ils
étaient complètement das quoi c'était de
la défisc voilà un malraux à malraux
exactement mais on a parlé tout à
l'heure alors moi je veux qu'on demande
à des gens qui nous regardent à faire le
bon choix déjà comment est-ce qu'on peut
flairer une annonce suspects quand tu
vous parlez de location d'achat on va
dire la location ce qui est beaucoup de
gens qui louent drc un problème il ya
des gens qui achètent mais c'est plus et
plus souvent dans les locations qui a
des problèmes que dans la queue dans
l'achat comme après c'est vrai pour la
location là où il ya le plus d'armes
accès dans les locations de vacances
c'est pas tellement dans les locations
d'appartements pour tous les jours donc
on va distinguer les deux les deux types
d' arnaque dans la location de vacances
grosso modo si tu vis dans un deux
pièces à cergy toute l'année et que tu
te retrouves à avoir les moyens
d'acheter à de louer une villa au mois
d'août à saint tropez avec piscine et
agir il faut et il faut se poser une
question well as jusque-là du pachy
chromé mais
le principal le principal point auquel
il faut faire attention sur les sites
les plates formes de voyage qu'on
connaît tous ces les avis et c'est
surtout le celui qui met en location
l'appartement donc ça doit être ce qu'on
appelle un super host ça doit être un
type qui est réputé qui a fait toute une
tonne de voyages etc et il doit avoir
plein de commandes maintenant il ya des
arnaqueurs qui sont très très bien des
maux des commentaires etc c'est plus
difficile maintenant de mettre des faux
commentaires mais toutefois ça peut être
un vrai type qu avait une vraie baraque
avec des bons commentaires et qui tout
d'un coup est acculé de dettes et qui
décide de faire une arnaque donc il faut
encore se prémunir de ça et pour se
prémunir de ça c'est un peu une solution
de débrouille mais c'est la seule qui
vaut tu pars plus
quelqu'un sur place exactement est
exactement
c'est un peu gros pour les elle confère
un péage c'est par un repérage les gens
ils disent bouquet mais c'est trop dur
de faire un repérage partir en vacances
pour voir et en fait non sur des cibles
quand on peut citer des sites l'a13 cc3
tout va bien bon ok bah sur des sites
comme leboncoin je connais pas de titres
qui font comme leboncoin mais sur des
citoyens le père coin il ya des il ya
des auto-entrepreneurs qui offrent leur
adrià bnb vie c'est pas le même
situation pacha selon le site de ma
boîte si tu veux ou
donc il ya des gens sur le bon coin par
exemple qui sont autant entrepreneurs et
qui s'occupe de ça notamment avant les
vacances qui sont shaker de 2,2 ville a
donc ce type là c'est un auto
entrepreneur on lui fait on lui fait un
paypal on lui fait un virement n'importe
quoi et lui va juste vérifier déjà que
la baraque existe souvent les baraques
existe mais surtout il va taper à la
porte pour dire est-ce que vous avez
bien mis cette maison en location parce
que les scam donc les fausses annonces
c'est pas des fausses maison c'est des
vrais maison avec des vraies photos qui
existent réellement mais quand c'est
juste comme quand on arrive c'est pas la
même ouais alors tentez pas la même
sinon carrément le propriétaire des
bijoux et jérémy alloué
6 h
30 bal parce que c'est quand du du coin
en fait brut chaque les vacances c'est
donc certes il n'en sait rien du tout
cet avis devrait des loyers hors de prix
là aujourd'hui c'est un dans la zone
devrait vrai problème le roi léon grosse
et des basses et des prix bas c'est
pareil c'est parfait
c'est d'autant plus injuste que les
loyers hors de prix
ça concerne les gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens c'est souvent les prix des
petites surfaces vous le dire et voilà
c'est souvent dû 30 40 50 mètres carrés
et tu recherchais gaz réméré ouais même
plus petit et en plus ce qui est tout à
fait injuste dans ce truc là c'est que
ça concerne les gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens qui n'ont pas de bons dossiers
parce que grosso modo le type qui est
cadre chez airbus qui gagne sa vie lui
la le bas parce qu'il a un dossier
génial celui qui va avoir un problème
c'est celui qui est autant entrepreneurs
qui par exemple les vtc je dis ça au
hasard qui a pas un super dossier parce
qu'une fois les revenus ils fluctuent
comme ça et lui il a un problème à avoir
un appart et donc c'est lui qui va être
la victime de ce truc là il va devoir
payer un appart beaucoup plus cher parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver un
appart normal donc et une double
injustice en fait ouais mais il faut
savoir que dans la majorité des zones
tendues ma peine une zone tendue c'est
une zone où il n'y a pas de logements en
gros normalement les loyers sont
plafonnés je vais vous demander est ce
que les propriétaires peuvent demander
n'importe quel tarif alors normalement
non alors normalement demain sauf qu'il
ya des petites il ya des petites des
petites magouilles parce que c'est pas
des magouilles parce qu'on peut
s'arranger grosso modo quand on note
bien à quelque chose de particulier
kankankan le bien quelque chose de
particulier ou quand le louer en meublé
vous avez dû vous déjà entendu ce truc
là alors on a le droit de louer un petit
peu plus cher et malgré tout il ya quand
même des abus parce que la réalité c'est
que le type qui a un appart à faire un
investissement locatif et qui a envie de
booster un petit peu la renta il se dit
que jamais il va se rattraper et
malheureusement il se fait rarement
attrapé en revanche que je dois dire
c'est que vous en tant que locataire
vous avez les moyens de vérifier si vous
êtes au bon loyer et si vous n'êtes pas
au bon loyer vous pouvez alors une
simple lettre
lors de la bêta il rompt pas je vous
avais déjà donne six mois je veux demain
un appartement je suis mon bail à un
prix voilà jeunes importe quoi 800 euros
par mois une fois que le danger
maintenant et je me suis renseigné ouais
en fait le bon prix c'est pas à 8 ans et
6 700 jeu réellement faire un courrier
du chef des anciens de cieux bien sûr le
bail de n'doye à un bail c'est pas comme
un contrat sous seing privé c'est à dire
que l'on fait un bail mais on n'a pas le
droit dans le bail ne pas respecter la
loi c'est à dire que si le loyer
plafonné à 650 mal c'est pas parce qu'on
a fait un bail tous les deux et que j'ai
écrit 700 que que ça vaut donc on peut
on peut se plaindre on peut écrire une
lettre au propriétaire en lui disant
c'est pas le bon loyer et normalement on
leur met au banc loyer ou on peut verser
le bon loyer alors je vous dis pas que
le bail va être renouvelée oui c'est ça
tu peux te [ __ ] dehors après leur
amère alors non mais
je suis d'accord mais je dis pas que le
bail ne va pas être va être renouvelée
facilement mais en tout cas on va payé
le bon prix et c'est où qu'on se
renseigne qu un nouveau recours bon
prive.com bon
français pour se renseigner sur les
loyers c'est
alors si ça à paris il ya plafonnement
des loyers ça le site de la mairie de
paris et franchement pour être tout à
fait franc je ne sais pas pour les
autres villes
enfin c'est enfin c'est assez facile
comme comme info a trouvé c'est pas du
tout un truc c'est pas du tout un truc
secret où il faut être initié au sur
google on trouve d'ailleurs on parle
beaucoup c'est de la discrimination
quand on cherche un appartement ça c'est
un problème considérable c'est vrai que
c'est un cas sur trois quasiment là
est-ce que des recours au pouvoir des
images qui avaient été faites pour
celles des caméras cachées ces horribles
d'ailleurs quand on va la regarder
maintenant on va parler juste après
gens qui ont envie d'en saisir d'un
appartement grand conseil dans les
années un couple sur ces appartements
achetés au restaurant
mais les enfants partent il est le furan
le dur en ce lundi ce qu'avance à
loutraki la version la lutte au crime un
marteau un souci c'est que sur le
terrain les valeurs je pourrais me
casser tous deux démissionné ils sont
assez
ferme ils sont favoris ils ont mis tout
son corps et dans la formule qui ont
bien accompli ce que ça sur les chances
le pugnace de dubai - c'est la chesnaie
des gens
les gens
[Musique]
sont des gens ce n'est plus que nous pas
comment mais nos
[Musique]
cassettes vidéo elle est déjà copieuse
c'est là qu'on va voir maintenant c'est
encore plus trash regard des corps plus
trash que ça
[Musique]
entre le docteur
fu chi rang on a des voisins a touché
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est la réalité ans arrive
extrêmement fréquemment d'un est-ce
qu'on a un recours contre ça est ce
qu'on peut se battre contre ce genre de
discrimination quand on et voilà on va
faire faire un loyer iric peut-être moi
ça m'est déjà arrivé ça alors il sait
prendre le train sans billet non mais
c'est vrai que c'est scandaleux parce
que franchement de mettre des gens comme
ça dans des catégories c'est pas parce
qu'on est renois quoi forcément foutent
le bordel ou presque ont revu
franchement moi ça me tue quoi ça me tue
ça me tue c'est question qu'est ce qu'on
a comme comme qu'on reconnaît david
contre ça ils agissent savez pas vous
aviez tourné dans mon agence
prenons un cas concret eric bas dans une
agence voilà maintenant il a un dossier
tout à fait correct voilà avec un fiche
de paie déclarations d'impôt tout est
parfaitement car est il allé revenu il a
trois fois les revenus pour louer et y
comprend qu'en fait il aura jamais la
parte parce que il est black aces qui la
lui a recours contre le stress alors
aucun recours ces mecs c'est à dire non
non mais ouais même c'est à dire que
c'est au choix du propriétaire donc nous
on est administrateur de biens aussi
donc on a des propriétaires qui ne
disent ah non ce on se protège en disant
mais écoute non non rien à [ __ ] il
faut juste qu'ils soient éligibles
d'assurance reliant payer nous c'est
c'est notre discours on dit noir arabe
juif breton on n'en a rien à faire s'il
est éligible aux assurances aux liens à
payer on le prend mais la réalité c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de recours si le type
est assis ça veut dire que le
propriétaire on lui propose les dossiers
si le propriétaire
même l'agent ce n'est pas raciste du
tout le proprio l'agencé propose des
dossiers si le propriétaire est même pas
ta gueule il prend pas et c'est horrible
mais c'est comme ça et est alors si
après il ya une preuve avérée de racisme
alors
pour racisme et je veux dire il faut le
prouver ben oui mais il faut prouver
c'est à dire que quand on loue un appart
dans des zones tendues véritablement
vous avez un appart à louer vous recevez
15 20 appels par jour véritablement donc
c'est presque normal de ne pas avoir la
partie et il faut prouver ça parce qu'on
le dit pas aux locataires le locataire
et propose son dossier et on lui envoie
un mail en lui disant que son dossier
n'a pas été retenu dans le meilleur des
cas parce que dans le meilleur parce que
la majeur k
qu'on parle de seconde d'un traumatisme
pour les français c'est les
déménagements d'abord alors déménagement
il ya tous les prix ça que ça va deux
jeunes importe quoi pour imprimer pour
un petit cube âge de mille 1000 milles
euros à 10000 euros il ya des idées de
vivre absolument un peu quelle éthique
alors comment on fait la différence
entre quelqu'un qui est sérieux ou pas
déjà entre une agence qui propose un
service correct est quelqu'un qui va se
marier avec un homme
alors contrairement à tout ce que j'ai
dit avant cette fois je vais mettre un
petit peu de pincettes à ce que je dis
parce que c'est pas mon c'est pas mon
job premier c'est pas mon travail c'est
à dire que moi les déménagements c'est
pas mon corps de métier alors il s'avère
qu'avec mes clients j'en entend souvent
parler donc je connais il ya eu des
galères c'est à dire que des galères
ouais y'a que des galères simplement
encore une fois je mets des guillemets à
ce que je dis mes clients qui sont
satisfaits de passer par des bottes de
déménagement c'est des gens qui sont
passés par des sites nationaux tels que
seloger bien ici et c'est qu'ils mettent
en contact avec des boîtes de
déménagement et ses boîtes là et ça je
vous le dis en tant qu'entrepreneur
halpern a redit hier met d'avoir des
mauvais avis parce qu'elles sont choisis
en fonction des avis des gens c'est à
dire qu'il faut être référencés sur
seloger qu'avec le fameux label
exactement avoir 4,75 sur 5 pour être
référencés sur seloger donc encore une
fois alors là je suis je suis vraiment
désolé pour ça parce que je peux enfin
voila je suis pas aussi sûr de moi que
je l'étais avant pour les questions
d'avant mais disons que moi quand je
déménage je prends les boîtes qui sont
recommandées par les sites nationaux et
qui sont encore une fois très bien notée
mais sincèrement il ya que des galères
c'est comme les travaux dès qu'on fait
appel à des gens un corps de métier qui
nécessite pas beaucoup de formations et
ben on a souvent des cartes jeux pour
console conditions qu'on peut dire de 30
mètres cubes ce qui est à la ferme du
déménagement est ce qu'on a appris
moyens et qu'on peut se dévoila ou
globalement de payer tant l'agencé le
franchement en fait on peut pas répondre
parce que ça dépend de la distance c'est
ça en fait c'est à dire si on déménage
sur le même palier c'est évidemment
encore une fois je vous prends pas pour
des abrutis mais et c'est
le volume cc c'est une histoire le
volume et la distance démêlage l'étagé
l'ascenseur alors bizarrement ça
changement dans le devis pas d'accord
bizarrement
sauf pour les pièces extraordinaires
petit piano et c'était avec faut une
grue la change mais ça change pas dans
le devis est d'habiter au cinquième
étage c'est vrai que c'est bizarre mais
mais ça change dans le devis cd cd c'est
des trucs qu'on croit mais qui en fin de
compte ne sont pas gras comme les
rez-de-chaussée on dit que les
rez-de-chaussée sont plus souvent
cambrioler l'assurance vol pour un
rez-de-chaussée coûte le même prix que
l'assurance d'un deuxième étage donc
plus cher serait donc travaux en gros
soyez soyez vigilants merci beaucoup
d'amis
[Applaudissements]